good evening thank you very much for
coming ladies and gentlemen this is the
scariest book of the year believe me its
author is associate professor and chair
or the journal is an apartment of st.
Michael's College in Vermont before
coming to st. Michael's David Mendes
worked as an assignment editor for CNN
well it wasn't exactly an assignment
editor when he got out of Brandeis
University in 85 he had no idea what he
wanted to do with his life so he worked
in radio and was a club DJ in London the
man knows how to live he returned to his
native New York City and took a
production assistants job at CNN then he
worked out wrote scripts cut tape edited
packages feel produced and finally
became an assignment editor after that
he returned to school getting a master's
the PhD at NYU we went to st. Michael's
in 1996 in addition to this book he'd
agreed another called just the facts how
objectivity came to define not decline
American journalism and then this book
tuned out he's written many many
articles he has a multi-page resume with
papers that he has written articles and
all the rest among other things David
founded J history an internet group for
journalism historians in 1994 in 1998-99
he was head of the history division of
the AE JMC which is journalism educators
is that right David I think in 2002 the
age AMC awarded mid ditch
the Krieg bomb under 40 award for
outstanding achievement and research
teaching and public service an amazing
record for under 40 he lives in
Burlington Vermont with his wife Barbara
Richmond whom he met at CNN and their
two children and now he's going to tell
you about those two children and all our
other children out there in America and
and what they're up to as Eve said
fasten your seatbelts this is going to
be a bumpy night David thank you very
much i want to thank the overseas press
club for the invitation to speak today I
would especially like to thank Sonja fry
the executive director of the club for
organizing this event I'll speak for
about 25 minutes before taking questions
and hopefully there'll be a discussion
I'd like to talk today about how
Americans particularly young Americans
don't follow the news and I'd like to
talk about how it tuned out electorate
effects our democracy and our place in
the world it's been about a week since
the election and already there's been a
lot of speculation about civic
engagement and young people and news
consumption the first thing we learned
is that the percentage of young people
who voted did actually rise slightly in
the eighteen to thirty crowd about forty
percent voted in the two thousand
election now it's about fifty percent so
I think that's really good news the
overall percentage of 18 to 30 year olds
percentage of the electorate as a whole
stayed exactly the same at seventeen
percent and young people split their
vote about forty-five percent voted for
bush
and fifty-four percent voting for Carrie
so it was the young people didn't have
the effect on the election that
especially Carrie supporters had hoped
the second thing that we have learned
about the election and the thing that's
been talked about a lot is that
Republicans won on values and I think
this is not true it's true that about
twenty-two percent of americans polled
say that moral values was their central
issue and most of those folks voted for
bush but i think a more significant
number is this half of all americans say
that the war in iraq has made us safer
half of all americans still believe that
Saddam is responsible for 911 even
though Bush and his administration has
admitted that note I exists seventy
percent of Bush supporters believe
there's a clear link between Saddam and
al-qaeda eighty-five percent of Bush
supporters say that the Iraq war is
going well more than because of values I
think Bush won because many people were
uninformed this is not to say that
Carrie supporters were all informed did
all carry supporters add up the social
programs that he was proposing the
universal health care and the
implications of middle-class tax cut
well no but on the bush side i think
that the connections in this case are
very clear so i'm going to talk today
though about a even bigger issue than
one election i'm going to talk about the
decades-long decline in news consumption
this election i think is just a taste of
what a tuned out America can feel like
the post-soviet era leaves us with one
superpower all power needs to be checked
whether it's Democratic power or
Republican power
so what's the check on the presidency in
this case the presidency is not fully
checked by a congress because the
Congress both houses of Congress share
the same party as the president the
Supreme Court has served as somewhat of
a check on presidential power recently
the Supreme Court has said that American
citizens including jose padilla and
yasir Hamdi cannot be held indefinitely
without charges so the Supreme Court has
served as somewhat of a check but
ultimately who is the ultimate check
it's us it's you and me we are the
ultimate check on presidential power and
on any governmental power it's an
informed citizenry informed by a free
and aggressive press we individually and
collectively are an important part of
the government it's a sense of ownership
I think that we really need to foster in
all Americans particularly in young
Americans and I'll tell you a quick
story i was in montpelier vermont i live
in in Burlington Vermont and in
Montpelier on pillars of an interesting
state capital I think it's the only
state capital without a McDonald's of
all 50 and it's also the only state
capital without a security guard so you
can actually walk in to the capitol
building and go into the Senate chambers
go into the house chambers and there's
no security guard so I was walking with
my seven-year-old son a few months ago
and I was holding his hand and he was
getting very nervous and he was holding
my hand tighter and tighter and he said
dad I don't think we're allowed in here
and I said don't worry and he said I
really don't think were loud in here so
I said okay all I ask a guard of course
there's no guard so I said so we finally
saw someone I think it was a young man
who was a senator a state senator and I
said to him sir is it okay for me and my
son to be in this building and he said
something which is so beautiful
he said of course you can be here it's
your house and I think it's very
beautiful i hope he will think it's
beautiful too i keep on repeating the
story enough so so i'm sure that one day
he'll he'll realize the beauty of it but
there's a sense of ownership that i
think that we need to instill it's our
house it's our Vermont it's our new york
it's our America that part of this whole
equation about why young people aren't
following the news is a sense that they
don't take ownership over their house
part of taking ownership is following
news about our house and in that way
things have really declined about 30
years ago half of all college students
read a newspaper every day half of all
college students read a newspaper every
day today it's one in five um but that's
maybe not a surprise that college
students don't read a newspaper every
day but I think what's maybe more
surprising is that 20-somethings don't
read in the newspaper every day and most
30-somethings don't read a newspaper
every day and actually reminds me of a
New Yorker article I read a few years
ago about people's taste in music and
the the thesis of the article was that
if you haven't brought into your musical
tastes by the time you're in your early
or mid 20s you never will so your
musical tastes are fixed in your early
20s the same isn't it is true with news
if you don't read a newspaper by the
time you're 25 typically you never pick
up the habit there are exceptions but
that's pretty much the rule so people
say to me they're not reading the
newspaper that's because they're
watching TV news so does anyone want to
venture a guess what the median viewer
age of the network evening news is 60
actually that's correct it used to 10
years ago it was 50 and now it's 60 so
that means for every person watching dan
Rather Tom Brokaw and pre de
Jennings below the age of 60 there's a
person above the age of 60 watching the
evening news and if you find that
statistic as mind-blowing as I find it
watch the evening news but don't watch
the news itself watch the commercials
it's like opening up the medicine
cabinet of an elderly couple products
like viagra Metamucil fix it end you see
this over and over again in the news and
you know any broadcaster tries to target
its youngest audience because they want
to hook their youngest audience for life
on a particular product that's why shows
that that have a 20-something audience
or even a teen audience are so popular
because you want to hook somebody on
coca-cola for the rest of their lives
you want to get them when they're 14 so
you can tell that if they're trying to
reach the younger audience of the news
it still is is an older audience so one
of the responses that I have to the book
when I when I mention these two facts
about newspapers and television one of
the responses is well they're getting
the news off the internet when young
people were asked about a year ago
what's your preferred source of news
eleven percent said the internet and
many people are actually getting the
news of off the internet and I think
it's probably higher than 11 especially
this last election but but when you look
at what people are following on the
Internet it's typically email instant
messenger entertainment news if you go
to a college computer lab or a high
school computer lab what you see is a
lot of email instant messenger
entertainment and not so much following
the news some people have developed a
really key news sense over the Internet
some people go really deep and I've
spoken to a lot of young people in my
research
who've actually achieved a level of
depth about topics such as Israel or
Afghanistan or Democratic senators or
republican congressman or whatever that
a level of conversin see that maybe
people have not been able to get in the
past but that's still a small minority
so if young people aren't getting the
news from all these news sources where
are they getting the news well I think
one of the most important things that I
found is that many young people aren't
getting the news from anywhere that
they're not even getting even the broad
outlines of what it means what they need
to be good citizens in the year in 2004
in this last election Americans of all
ages were asked who was the Democratic
it was in the height of the Democratic
presidential primary who was the
candidate who was a general that's they
were asked this question about a forty
percent of older Americans knew it was
Wesley Clark about eleven percent of
younger Americans news Wesley Clark so
why is this important incidentally the
same question was asked four years ago
who was the candidate that sponsored
campaign finance reform in the Senate
twenty-five percent of all Americans
knew it was John McCain five percent of
younger Americans knew it was John
McCain so why is it important I think
it's important because to be a good
citizen to hold our leaders accountable
we need to know the basic outline of
their biographies we need to know their
signature piece of legislation we need
to know basic political facts about them
and we need to know basic political
facts about the world so we can contrast
leaders claims with what we know so
where young people always as more tuned
out than their elders well studies have
shown that in the 40s and the 50s and
the 60s and the 70s young people
typically knew almost as much as their
elders and this has declined
this is declined since then and we're
seeing as I said a lot of people in
their 20s and in the 30s who were also
tuned out so armed with these facts I
went around the country talking with
young people i talked with bankers in
Kansas City I talked with junior
basketball players in Los Angeles and
actors in Los Angeles I talked with a
college students and brandeis university
right outside of Boston I went down to
New Orleans and spoke with junior high
school kids in New Orleans and then also
a bunch of students in my hometown of
Vermont Burlington Vermont many people
were very uninformed but I should say
that the young people that I spoke with
were very thoughtful as well the I've
been teaching for 15 years at the
college level and I've always been
incredibly impressed with the idealism
of young people with the thoughtfulness
the intelligence and I think the most
important thing that I want to say
before I go into some of the reasons why
young people are tuning out of the news
I want to say that I I don't blame young
people as a group and it's also
important to realize that the trend
began in the early 70s so it wasn't the
teenagers of today who began the trend
but in many cases it was their parents
are the media to blame well i think yes
and no yes because of the shrinking news
hole in many newspapers yes because big
companies are trying to wring every
penny out of their of their local
newspapers local broadcast stations yes
because in trying to make the news
matter to young people they seem to make
the news matter to nobody by injecting
britney spears into copy and other
things that they think that young people
will suddenly gravitate towards the
newspaper for
and no I think that we can't blame
journalism because journalism great
journalism happens every day in the New
York Times The Wall Street Journal and
in hundreds of local newspapers across
America time doesn't give me a time
doesn't permit me to go into all the
reasons for the decline but i just want
to mention a few things first
entertainment the lure of entertainment
has always been greater than the lure of
politics a few years back researchers
asked how many Supreme Court justices
you could name and seventeen percent of
Americans could name three or more
Supreme Court justices 57% could name
three of the three stooges well I think
there are more than three I should say
because there's also curly Joe and Shep
right so they all account but there are
nine Supreme Court justices so my own
research has found that ninety six
percent of the people i spoke with could
name Alicia Keys could identify Alicia
Keys the singer seven percent could name
all three of the country's mentioned by
Bush as the axis of evil most couldn't
name even one Supreme Court justice so
many people say that the big change in
the media universe has been the advent
of 24-hour news I would argue that in
fact a bigger change has been that news
as a footprint of the media universe has
really shrunk so for example one of the
things I did in writing this book was I
looked at the page the TV page from the
New York Times from 1968 the night that
Walter Cronkite made his famous remark
that we are mired in stalemate in
Vietnam so I looked I wanted to find out
what his competition was
um he he was up against three news shows
three news and public affairs shows and
a movie F Troop and I Love Lucy so there
were seven stations in New York at the
time and those of you who are old enough
to remember that the remote control was
done like this right so on that evening
if you were going to look at at Walter
Cronkite you would go physically go
through each channel and you'd have a
one in seven chance of getting Cronkite
a three and seven chance for in seven
chance of getting news or public affairs
and the minority of choices would be a
movie and entertainment so now things
have changed quite radically at that
time TV dinners family dinners were kind
of giving way to TV dinners but since
then more and more young people have
televisions in their own room operating
with their televisions at a different
rhythm in nineteen seventy-six percent
of sixth graders had televisions in
their own room today it's something like
eighty percent and they're not watching
dan Rather Tom Brokaw or Peter Jennings
in their own room at a brandeis
university I spoke with a group of
college students asking them what their
choices are and why they choose
entertainment or news and one brand a
student said that with entertainment and
video games there's a sense of emotional
investment in instant gratification
against this he said is the detachment
of campaign finance reform and Peter
Jennings and Peter Jennings was simply
seen as this stock figure that's much
less interesting this avuncular kind of
boring guy that wasn't nearly as
interesting as the entertainment choices
and I think that leads us to one
important thing to remember that when we
put up news against entertainment
and two saw try to figure out you know
how can we make news as entertaining as
entertainment we lose every time because
we can't we can't make news as
entertaining in 1982 dan Rather did
something really radical to compete with
his rivals he tried wearing a sweater
with his suit and tie and that was only
effective though if your news universe
consisted of two other middle-aged white
guys with suits he can't compete on the
entertainment value with Victoria
Sinclair the reason why he can't compete
with Victoria Sinclair is because
through his newscast dan Rather remains
fully clothed Victoria Sinclair who is
the anchor of Naked News calm disrobes
during her newscast as she tells the
news straight and is taking off her
clothes it's no surprise that while dan
Rather show has seen a decline in young
people news consumption Victoria
Sinclair has seen an explosion but in
chasing young viewers rather Brokaw and
Janning should not try to be like
Victoria Sinclair for a whole range of
reasons but you know Naked News is not a
news organization it reads but it does
not report it on dresses but it does not
uncover it's a show dog not a watchdog
despite the entertainment value of Naked
News com we need our journalists clothes
for battle so Yogi Berra once said if
the fans don't come out to the ballpark
you can't stop
the news industry thinks it can compete
with the entertainment value of friends
and fear factor but it can't but here
are some things that the news business
might do to try to compete with with
entertainment first thing is journalists
could try to interject more passion into
their news stories the objectivity has
its place and certainly non-partisanship
having a voice outside of the political
parties is very important but at the
same time I think you can be nonpartisan
and yet show that you care Fox News
which I'm going to argue in a second is
a terrible news source has certain
things to be said for it one is passion
people seen on Fox to care about what
they're covering other journalists like
Bill Maher and keith olbermann on cable
seemed to care about what they're
covering Bill Moyers show when he talks
about poverty he seems to care a lot he
seems to have a lot of passion about
that it doesn't necessarily have to be a
partisan issue to care and I think that
um one of the reasons why Jon Stewart in
the daily show is so successful well one
of the reasons is because it's so funny
but another reason is that he seems to
care about the stories he's covering he
seems to infuse passion into his stories
so I think that the CNN model the
network model of emotional detachment
might be reconsidered of course our
passion shouldn't get in the way of our
judgment recent study looked at fox
viewers and found that they are
considerably less informed than viewers
of other media all viewers and consumers
of news were asked about three fallacies
of the Iraq war won that world opinion
was solidly behind the Iraq war the
second was that there was a connection
between Saddam Hussein and nine
11 and the third was that weapons of
mass destruction had been found fox
viewers believed one or more of those
fallacies eighty percent of the time
much higher than newspaper readers or
PBS Watchers or NPR listeners so if
you're a news executive at Fox you
should be horrified by this because the
objective of any news organization is to
inform your public to make your public
smarter not Dumber to make your your
public better armed to to be a check on
presidential and other governmental
power another thing we can do is we can
offer more road maps in our newspapers
and in our broadcast outlets a student
of mine once said that following the
news was like entering a math class
midway through the semester and trying
to keep up and I think that it's really
important for journalists to keep that
particular student in mind you know as
you're writing a story what do you need
to do to tell that young person who
wants to engage in the news a little bit
of more information so that the young
person can do that if you're writing a
story about Kenya you might want to do a
sidebar about the history of Kenya if
you're writing a story about democratic
or republican candidates give a little
bit of background a little more
background so that someone who honestly
wants to get into the news can do that
for the first time the biggest changes
however I think can have to be made
outside of the newsroom and for this
I'll just tell you a quick story I was
in New Orleans talking with
african-american junior high school boys
there's a school Catholic school that
only accepted african-american boys
whose families were below the poverty
line and I was talking about their news
consumption so I said you happen to know
who the Secretary of State is and one
boy said Donald Rumsfeld
and I said no but that's close how do
you know Rumsfeld so he said well I read
his name on the New York Times Online I
said you read the New York Times Online
you know New Orleans poor kid you know
middle school kid and I was surprised
and he said yeah in sixth grade my my
teacher asked us to read the New York
Times online and get the email prompts
and two years later I still get the
email prompts and still look at the time
so you can get world news from it and I
looked around the table and and the
other boys were nodding their heads and
around the table there were five boys
four of them had taken the class all
four of them were still on the New York
Times Online two years after they were
asked to do it and I thought wow you
know this is it's possible to to even
get you know kids in New Orleans really
far from a New York City to read the New
York Times it made me think that maybe
there are things that we can do to
change our expectations in school we
might offer a csat civics s80 test maybe
10 questions on the s80 devoted to news
and civics we ask all sitting all people
who want to become citizens in this
country to take a civics test why not
offer a non-binding civics test for all
18 year olds we won't kick them out of
the country if they can't pass but maybe
the college's could notice and provide
an extra goad for people to to follow
the news and stay civically engaged we
can Lobby the FCC in the nineteen late
1960s and early 70s I was I was a kid
watching cartoons in the morning on
saturday mornings and sandwich in
between the cartoons there was a show
called in the news and i still remember
the newscaster christopher glen his
voice giving the news reports from from
around the world and around the country
and
that really whetted my appetite for news
why doesn't that exist sandwiched in
between all cartoons well it's our fault
really because the FCC can insist on it
and we can lobby the FCC the art the
airwaves belong to us so why not insist
that more of the airways be devoted to
news and public affairs the problem is
the broadcaster's no longer have that
fear that their license will be will be
renewed will be will be denied and we
can bring that fear back and I think the
fear would be a good thing we need to we
need to give people a more compelling
reason to tune back into the news we
need to make news important for
conversation for education for the
workplace and those are the ways that we
can make people pay attention finally a
media critic James W carry from Columbia
University once said that the purpose of
journalism is to make sure that we don't
get screwed I think that that's actually
one of the most beautiful definitions of
journalism to make sure that we don't
get screwed and I think that's what it's
all about it's about democracy the
leaders who are unchecked do outrageous
things every time and without the
knowledge that without news knowledge
young people and all Americans really
seed their political power to those who
stay involved they see their political
power to their elders and to their age
cohorts who stay involved and stay
engaged another quick story before I
finish my teenage daughter is just
finished 1984 and I think 1984 should be
required reading by all teenagers
especially during an election year
because of all of the Orwellian rhetoric
that goes around in any election year on
both sides particularly this year
perhaps and it's important for young
people to be skeptical about what
politicians are saying but 1984 is not
good enough 1984 gives you a start to be
skeptical but also you need something
else and there's something else you need
is to have enough facts to contrast what
a leader is saying with the facts on the
ground in we've heard recently claims
that the war in Iraq is going really
well but careful readers of many
newspapers including a well in my cases
the New York Times would know that in
one month I think was the month of
September 2,300 separate attacks were
conducted on on coalition and Iraqi
security forces 2,300 in one month and
actually a very interesting statistic of
those 799 or homemade bombs which to me
very quickly told me of the level of
chaos in Iraq to remain vigilant and
skeptical we need to embrace a paradox
to build a healthy skepticism we need to
find information that we can trust and
this is the paradox a recent poll said
that 75% of young people trusted the US
military would do the right thing this
was up from about twenty percent in the
1970s so twenty percent of 1970s
believed that the military would do the
right thing now it's 75 percent at the
same time trust in the media has
declined it used to be fifty-four
percent and now it's thirty-six percent
so far more people trust the military
than trust the media
and trust in government has its place
you need to have put some level of trust
in the government but we also need to
trust the watchdogs so my message to
young people has always been that you
need to find journalism that you can
trust because you need to be able to
build up a case to support or to go
against your leaders we need to hold
leaders accountable and we need the
watchdogs to help us finally it's been
said that America is a system designed
by geniuses so that it could be run by
idiots but this is not entirely true the
Constitution does provide checks against
the greatest mistakes of the moment and
elections do provide a quick check
sometimes against the government's
neglect of the people but nothing in our
Constitution protects us against the
long-term ravages of neglect by the
people themselves and I think we need
news because we need to hold our leaders
accountable and I would argue that our
democracy depends on it thanks
I think we have time for questions but
there are there's a person with a
microphone that's going to be coming
around so if you could wait before you
ask the question if you could raise your
hand and then we'll wait and there's
also a microphone in the middle of the
room as well so feel free to to use that
as well yes are the young people that
you talk to are they aware how ignorant
they are first second are they at all
embarrassed about this perhaps only when
you point it out and third do they have
any solution from their own lives or
their own experience how this could be
rectified okay well the first question
are they aware i think they are almost
to the person they say oh I just don't
know this is and they're also
embarrassed by it what's interesting is
that the people the level of
embarrassment does not correlate to how
much they know where they don't know so
one guy the most tuned out person in the
book that I that I interviewed was a guy
who could name six Supreme Court
justices and struggled with the seventh
and then couldn't get the eighth and
ninth and he was all day long he was
driving crazy I can't get the eighth of
nine Supreme Court justice so and the
same the same extent a young woman a
junior college basketball player in Los
Angeles who knew none of the answers to
my news questions except who was Allen
Iverson the basketball player and who is
Alicia Keys the the singer was also
terribly embarrassed and she said oh I
should really know this stuff this these
questions make me feel stupid so but
what to do about it it's interesting a
lot of people particularly when I ask
people are tuned out I said why don't
you follow the news and the answer
typically is we don't have time and
Robert Putnam who wrote a book called
Bowling Alone actually argued against
the time issue by saying that the
average American watches about four
hours of entertainment television a day
so clearly Americans young and old have
time for lots of things including
entertainment television but they're not
willing to make time for news typically
and I think that the reason is because
the New York Times or following the news
in general is hard work if you pick up
the wall street journal it's hard to get
through it and those of us who do follow
the news do it in part because of a
sense of citizenship but also because it
aids in conversation their workplace
expectations and educational
expectations so for me the reason why I
read the New York Times every day in
part is because I sit around the
cafeteria of my college every day and
sit with a few students and a few
professors who all read the newspaper
and I like to be able to keep up with
them and they like to be able to keep up
with me so we all follow news together
so I think that that that's part of the
problem and that the people who are
tuned out don't always seem to aren't
always aware of that taking the time as
part of the solution wait for that Mike
thanks a general question first of all I
don't find it so scary that young people
don't participate what would scare the
heck out of me is if older people don't
participate in democracy and my question
is is don't you find it more natural
that people participate in democracy and
the world around them as they acquire a
vested interest in it you yourself I
think the speaker said didn't know what
you wanted to do with your life when you
get out of college how in the world
would you be interested in the deficit
and so don't you find it a natural
evolution that young people don't
participate don't have the experience
don't have the vested interest to really
care but aren't you more encouraged by
the fact that all the people are
increasing their participation in
democracy as they acquire a vested
interest in it
have a more logical reason to
participate and one footnote the rest of
the uneducated world is almost dominated
by the political whims and fashions
Middle East for example in Mexico and
other countries were the overwhelming
number of people young people would you
put your faith and their participation
rather than older people i think it's
it's a really great question and the
question of of as you get older you buy
into the system more you're more vested
in the system and therefore you follow
the news more that's absolutely true
historically it's a it's absolutely true
that typically people as they would get
work as they would have raised a family
send their kids to school take a look at
their neighborhood and see what needs to
be changed they would invest in the news
the problem is that that pattern which
has existed for a long time has been
broken that typically someone in their
mid-20s 30 years ago would develop the
habit and I've spoken to lots of older
Americans who say uh yeah when I didn't
I didn't follow the news at all until I
was 25 years old I got married had kids
and I started reading the newspaper when
I realized I've got to start thinking
about the school system but one of the
things that's been happening is that
adolescents has been prolonged and
people a lot of people have been writing
about this that that um that Americans
typically start investing in their
communities later and by that time it's
too late to pick up the news habit so
what we have our thirtysomethings who
are not invested in the news and that I
think is the real difference now it may
be that the 30 somethings will wait
until they're in their mid-40s to follow
the news and and I'm hopeful you know
that that could be but I don't see any
evidence that it would be that way so I
think that um I think that that that's
the pattern that we hope for but um but
I don't always see it I don't know if
that answered your question
please
interest are also very conservative and
I think that a country and a culture can
only live with creative new things if
you look at the music it was a young
people who created the music that we
objected to it is true in art too so we
need young people to be interested but
also to see that they are empowered and
they have not been empowered yeah I
think that's right i think that you know
one thing that I tell young people when
i try to make the argument that should
start following the news and this is an
argument that i make oftentimes on a
daily basis my students are not more
tuned out than then then young people
around the country in fact they probably
are more tuned in but i'm still making
the the argument to my college students
every day you know you should follow the
newspaper should read the newspaper and
the thing that I say is you don't want
to cede political power to your elders
you need to take control and I think
that that's that's a really important
lesson and we don't need the thing is
that people don't have to know nine
Supreme Court justices it's it's okay
not to know those of you who are out
there who don't know nine Supreme Court
justice it's okay but to have a sense of
what the Supreme Court is doing to have
a sense of who the Attorney General is
and what he does to have a sense of the
president's tax policies and what
actually is happening in Iraq it's not
that hard to at least get enough of a
broad outline to empower your vote and
that's what we're talking about people
who just are the equivalent of
flatliners in terms of political
awareness and that's really where our
democracy i think is imperiled
I'm sorry I'm not sure if this works
okay I was actually just wondering what
do you think in terms of The Daily Show
and shows that nature do you think
that's a positive trend in terms of news
development even though it's such a
bastardization of the journalism and of
the news is that actually positive or is
it a sort of a negative development just
sort of feeding into the euthanasia of
what's going on in my generation right
well before I answer let me ask you what
do you think it's positive actually do I
mean I think even though it is you know
such a mutation of actual journalism I
do think it's a positive development I
think that it's providing news in some
form and actually entertaining kids I
know that you know i just recently
developed an interest in journalism i
just graduated from college and I
thought you know wow Daily Show this is
great and I started working on a new
show myself and I thought I kept
watching it and realizing the people in
my office actually looked to the Daily
Show as a form of you know what is my
generation tuning into what are they
talking about what are they listening to
and I did think it was a positive
development i want i learned a lot from
its name and today no I i love the daily
show and i watch it as as much as i can
because it's just so funny and he's such
a he takes such a critical look at the
news and politics and it's as I say it's
uh it's a perspective that probably the
news itself could borrow from more to
take a critical analytical look at
itself and at politics and have some fun
you know so I think that those are
important things to keep in mind i also
think that one of the things that news
critics critics of The Daily Show say is
well they're getting all their news from
The Daily Show and I think that's not
exactly right i suspect that most people
who watch The Daily Show are also
getting the news from other sources as
well even if it's their primary news
source I think they're probably getting
news from multiple sources because
simply because to hear jokes about john
kerry and george bush I mean you have to
have some interest in politics otherwise
you'll watch you know fear factor or
friends or something like that that it
shows that our political we actually
actually looked at
media patterns of a lot of the people
that I interviewed ask them what their
favorite TV shows are typically people
who were interested in shows like The
Sopranos or law and order or shows that
are kind of more information driven were
more likely to watch the news people who
are interested in shows like friends and
other sitcoms were less likely to watch
the news so there is some kind of
correlation there Thanks there's a
questioner yes I I agree with what you
were saying that at that an informed
citizenry is the prerequisite for a
functioning democracy and and so it led
me to wonder when you went around and
spoke to young people I assume you also
spoke to the teachers of young people
and teachers are generally understood as
having the responsibility to train
children to assume their adult
responsibilities and so thinking about
that and then thinking about Sputnik and
when America felt that it was in its
national interest to have children that
were good at math and science all of a
sudden math and science became important
nationally why not a mandatory civics
curriculum a civics and current affairs
curriculum starting in the grade schools
and going all the way up with that not
inculcate the habits of virtue and news
consumption that are indispensable I
think that's an excellent point and you
know one of the things that's one of the
things that happens is when you test for
just math and just reading things that
fall by the wayside are art and music
and civics and other things so the No
Child Left Behind and other national
initiatives oftentimes hurt our quest to
inform young people to become good
citizens and consumers of news and you
know able to hold their leaders
accountable so that's why I would
recommend that the you know the addition
of a civics portion of the s80 someone
actually criticized me for saying that
and I actually agree with the criticism
he sent me an email after i wrote a
piece in The Chronicle of Higher
Education about this and he said
actually you don't want to just have a
civics s80 you want it to be broadly
based that every 18 year old should take
some kind of civics test now you're
speaking more of you know all along the
schooling to get a taste of that and I
think that that's a really good point
that you know the more civics the more
we ask our students and expect our
students to follow the news i think the
the more vibrant our democracy will be
you talk about the news generically in
some ways the New York Times found its
and this is a Paragon for the all news
reporting found that it got Vietnam
wrong after a couple of months and had
to apologize and then au courant the
public editor had to have all these
letters printed and so forth well I mean
what what is the news are they start
with the times is a Paragon what if they
tell you they're reading The National
Enquirer for example or or the daily
news of the New York Post at the other
end of the scale right I think that um
you know I apply a utilitarian model to
this the greatest news for the greatest
numbers and so you know when when news
executives say well what we're going to
do as they did in Chicago and in cities
all over the country say well you know
I'm going to make a free newspaper I'll
take out all the politics and the boring
stuff and it'll be you know i'll give it
out for young people in the subway and
this these two papers chicago's red eye
and red streak or among the first to do
this in this country and and people are
following the news but it's not it's not
news that can inform your vote and hold
leaders accountable so i think that
those are two really important measures
so the National Enquirer cannot hold
your leaders accountable right I mean
they can tell you when the leaders are
born on other planets or
you know things like that but I mean
really if you're if you're really
looking for a new source to to make you
give you enough information to decide
whether the war in Iraq is a good thing
whether tax policies are things that you
support you know then you need a
reputable source and won't you know I
did I did spend my first five ten years
of my career both in graduate school and
later trying to talk about bias in the
news talk about objectivity in the lack
of objectivity I'm finding myself making
almost a counter-argument now which is
that good journalism exists that good
journalism exists and you have to find
it it may not be the new york times it
might be the wall street journal it
might be the baltimore sun or it might
be whatever it might be that it'll be a
mix of things supplemented by the
European press that you can get online
and supplemented by intelligent blogs or
whatever but I think that the way that
the measure that we need to to insist on
is that it's a mainstream publication
that will give not only one side the
side you agree with but the side you
disagree with and the idea is to take
two ideas and to knock them together and
two or more ideas and knock them
together and then that's the way that
you can grow intellectually by holding
your ideas up to scrutiny and to the
ideas on the opposite side so the
National Enquirer doesn't do that I
would argue that there are countless
sources that do do that both online and
in print and there are broadcast outlets
that can supplement that as well over
here in the front
in in speaking to young people that I
know I find many of them quite
well-informed and I just wonder whether
there's a skew between urban young
people and exurban young people in terms
of their knowledge of of the news yeah
it's I I guess I can't really comment on
urban versus exurban which I guess
you're referring to the election
patterns a few days ago but I can and I
did speak broadly about that there are
some really troubling statistics about
Bush supporters being misinformed about
basic policies particularly regarding
Iraq and Saddam Hussein but uh what's
interesting is that when I talk to
groups like this or when we're also
broadcasting to c-span I'm sure that the
people who are c-span junkies and there
and of all ages are probably saying well
I'm tuned in you know so often times I
think that we have to remind ourselves
that there's a huge world out there that
we're not talking about the engaged
group of young people that have always
been engaged that have always been
civically minded that have always been
active in local politics reading their
papers avidly now developing a
understanding of certain issues on the
Internet I think we're talking about
another group a larger group that really
are tuning out completely from the news
and you know it was really beautiful to
see the the increase in news awareness
and civic engagement in this last
election whether that will be sustained
is also another story as well the
midterm elections of 2002 the voting the
percentage of young people 18 to 24 who
voted was seventeen percent so that
means if I'm doing the math correctly
forever
young person who voted five stayed home
so that's really disturbing everyone
followed the 911 attacks but in the days
following 911 when there were issues
such as whether to federalize airline
security workers what the war in
Afghanistan was doing things like that
there was a tremendous drop-off in young
people following the news so the
question is how do we build as a society
a sustained interest in the news and in
politics that goes beyond a hotly
contested election and that's really you
know our challenge second row go back to
Jon Stewart one of the things about Jon
Stewart is that he's so passionate about
the news as opposed to Peter Jennings at
Al who try to be objective which i think
is a whole myth anyway I don't think
anybody's objective and then their
attempt to be objective they're boring
yeah I think that I think that's a
really good point i think that you can
be fair and you can be balanced and not
saying that Jon Stewart is but I think
that you can be fair and balanced and
also be less detached so I think that
you know if you think about the average
anchor tone that you know that the tone
of a reporter of an anchor nobody talks
to you that way right and and Jon
Stewart I think maybe might talk to
people the way that people talk across
the kitchen table more so you know a
part of it is engaging people of all
ages in a human-like way and I think
that I think you're right that that
might have that might be lost in the
news today another question over here
um I was 10 sorry i was wondering on the
high schools that you talked to is
channel one still in place because i
remember when i was in high school about
five six years ago um we were required
to watch you know the 15 minute news
program Anderson Cooper was the fourth
correspondent in Kosovo and that's when
I started to get involved and watching
journalism and its continued to you know
I'm a c-span junkie today very involved
and I was just wondering if the high
schools are still doing that today yeah
i think you know i started off the
project thinking that channel one was
was not a good idea because there's
commercials and you know kind of there
were there are some trade-offs with
schools having channel one in the school
system students are watch with along
with the news they watch commercials and
it brings you know kind of consumerism
perhaps into the classroom and so it's
very suspicious of it but since starting
the project a lot of people have come up
to me and said very similar things that
uh that oh well you know i got
interested in news from channel one and
so I think you know I'm kind of sold on
it i I'm actually not very familiar with
the product I've seen its web page and
I've seen a few broadcasts but i think
that at any time you you introduce news
into schools i think it's a plus
this loss of appetite of for the news I
want to make an observation and have you
comment on it across the culture
generally during these decades that
we've lost our appetite for the news
there used to be on television things
like Playhouse 90 and Studio One the
level of television over the past
decades has been going down the level of
Broadway theater has been going down
considerably there is no longer an
off-broadway phenomenon the classic
music stations that we used to have in
New York are all gone they used to be
half it does and now there might be one
movies I really are a MOBA now than ever
so it seems to me the whole cultural
drift we've lost our appetite for so
many things and is is the loss of you
know this business of tuning out does it
relate to that and what is happening to
us not all of us but a greater number of
us that this is happening yeah and I
think that's a great point we I think
that anytime you have a very few new
shows surrounded by a television
universe that's huge and that most that
mostly it's it's mindless I mean there's
a lot of good television but you're
swimming in a large sea of mediocrity
and TV has obviously been during this
time that you're describing the driving
force so I think that that that that's
part of the problem that the sea in
which the the news is swimming is is
polluted and it's it's a it seems
sometimes like an insurmountable problem
for more questions over here in the
early seventies this whole downward
trend began was that because of
Watergate Vietnam or the proliferation
beginning proliferation of entertainment
on television hmm I would say that it
probably wasn't Watergate because I
think that a lot of young people got
interested in journalism because of
Watergate although people have made the
argument that it eroded trust in
information sources and in politics
maybe that's that's an issue I don't
think it was Vietnam because I think
that one of the all-time most important
reasons for young people to tune in was
the draft so it may have been the end of
Vietnam more than Vietnam itself and the
third thing that you mentioned I forget
operation of entertainment on television
yes then I shouldn't have forgotten that
because I think perhaps I would argue
that that yeah I think that that's
probably the closest to what we have and
there's also the other thing is that
there's been a decline in political
involvement political affiliation at
that time decline in in a conversation
about the news which is of course a
circular argument but but these are all
important factors as well question over
here we can do the journalists to be
more upright Eve and more decisive they
had a major platform during the three
presidential debates where I was really
amazed at the motivator could not
challenge either president of the
senator on facts that were throwing each
other and I think young people like that
type of approach where the journeys can
be more aggressive to all the subject
being interviewed yeah I think that
that's a really good observation
and one of the problems is that we have
to make politics more meaningful one of
the ways we can do that is by taking
back the debates the debates are now run
by two parties so it's not a non
partisan debate Commission so bipartisan
debate Commission and they set up all
the the ground rules we can we can have
a we can have a push to have that that
debate format be strengthened so that's
an important part I would argue that um
that if a candidate wants federal
matching funds the candidate should have
to announce political affiliation on
their ads for example it used to be that
you'd have an ad that would say Johnson
you know Democrat for Senate typically
that's eroded now it's you know Johnson
for a change and political affiliation
is not a good thing in terms of the
focus groups but I think we need to kind
of insist that politicians announce
their political affiliation so that
young people can be educated about the
political differences another part of
your question I think suggests to me
that the European press has been much
better at holding its leaders
accountable well we know that there's
question time in Britain where the the
leader of the country is held up to the
scrutiny of the other party and that
happens every week we we know that i
know of some BBC reporters who might ask
a question ten different times if the
person doesn't answer it and wouldn't
that be great if we did more of that so
yeah I think we need to hold people more
accountable it's it's also one of the
problems is that the current
administration holds rallies that that
only has people answering asking
questions of the same political party I
mean you know it only supports the
porters can ask questions which is a
terrible thing too terrible for our
democracy so there are a whole range of
things that we can do to make politics
more vibrant and
I think one of the most important
messages most important things that I
learned which is that we need to think
outside of the newsroom we need to think
about politics we need to think about
education about workplace about society
as a whole it's not just the newsroom
because and it's not just young people
it's all of us working together and it's
not just the presidential elections it's
staying involved in the county races in
the municipal races in the midterm
elections we need to really invest in
politics and have people stay involved
more and more I understand we we're
running out of time maybe we have time
for one more question why don't you take
the mic
how would you suggest that you get
children involved at the home level like
I would guess you know from what I have
a good friend who knows you pretty well
do you know your daughter is passionate
about politics do you do that around the
dinner table how do you do that hi
that's that's a great that's a great
question i think that you do that that
that the dinner table is the place to
talk about politics a lot of people say
to me well I can't let my kids watch the
news because the world is a really scary
place and I'm sympathetic to that I
often don't let my kids watch the news
but there's got to be an avenue of
introducing kids to the news because the
world is a scary place if you follow the
news but I would argue that it's even
scarier if you don't follow the names
because then you see bombs and
explosions and wars without meaning so
there's got to be away and I don't I
don't necessarily have the answer but
there's got to be a way to to talk about
it at the dinner table to introduce
maybe a newspaper or a magazine such as
Newsweek or time there's a great
magazine for kids called up front and I
wish more kids more teenagers would
would read it it's put out by the new
york times and it would be great if the
magazines that my daughter reads up
front because I i buy it for her but she
also reads other like teen magazines and
my daughter and I recently talked about
this that that there's nothing in
between the teen magazines which are
interested in mmm and britney spears and
and celebrities and something like
upfront so it'd be great if someone
could could and could marry the two and
two interest kids in the celebrity news
that they want but also say you know
what how is my magazine for teens
serving democracy
and it would be great to be able to
marry the two and I think would be a
great business plan if someone wants to
take the idea on but it would certainly
serve democracy as well so I think it's
up to our parents it's up to the media
and it's up to also young people
themselves to really embrace the world
that they live in a lot of young people
say that you know my vote doesn't matter
but our vote does we have to embrace the
collectivity we have to embrace the
weenus of our country in order to have
people understand the connections that
they have with each other and the ways
that they can hold their leaders
accountable thank you very much